if you could wipe one group off the
Earth who would it be cyclist done done
we're done with cyclists there's a
difference between someone who rides a
bike and a cyclist you ride a bike you
go from A to B I hate these you
see that got like the the tights and the
shirt and there's like a logo on it I'm
like well you got sponsors what are you
doing the Tour de France no you're 40
and you have no personality and you live
in the suburbs and you got something
else to do so you spend a bunch of money
on this and now you're like oh
it's a it's like the embodiment of
suburban consumerism slapped on a person
and then they inconvenience you as
you're driving it's all so many things I
hate on top of itself